absolutely phenomenal stuff from the
moms for Liberty and the Berkeley County
School District in South Carolina but
you're seeing this around the country
there was another mother she just showed
up to a school board meeting in Texas
she showed up to this school board
meeting and she just read from a book
that is in the school library uh
listener discretion advised if your kids
are listening right now maybe just skip
ahead you know 30 seconds or a minute uh
listen to the way that the board reacts
to the book that is in the school
library
but we fill our minds with matters
consider that as I read this from a
current library book
this one couple stumbled into my room
and asked if they could use the room
anyway with me still in it they closed
the door and started kissing after a few
minutes the boy's hand went up the
girl's shirt and she started protesting
pretty soon he took off her bra and
started to kiss her breasts and then he
put his hand down her pants and she
started moaning he reached to take off
her pants but she started crying really
hard so he reached for his own he pulled
his pants and underwear down to his
knees please Dave no but the boy just
talked stuff to her about how good she
looked and she grabbed with her hands
and started moving it the boy pushed the
girl's head down and she started to kiss
his
she was still crying finally she stopped
crying because he put his breath in her
mouth and I don't think you can cry in
that position I ask you why this book
Thank you survived two attempts your
time is that thank you so much and there
is a there's a child in our boardroom so
I'd like for you to please stop reading
that
did you see the child
okay then your your time is up thank you
so they cut off her microphone so you
can't hear her response but you can hear
the people laughing in the audience she
says excuse me ma'am there's a child
here you need to stop reading from the
books in our school library there's a
child here you're gonna go and say yeah
right that's the point the mother's
there she goes no I didn't see the child
but that's the point what are you
talking about ma'am that's very
pornographic and obscene and not
appropriate for children stop reading
the books that we put in our libraries
out loud
don't read the books that we're teaching
your kids
no the real reason that the school board
doesn't want that mother to read the
book is not because a child might hear
it it's because the other parents might
hear it and the other parents might
realize what insane radicals are running
the schools so this is good stuff it's
good when the parents come out there and
expose this stuff
it's good when the handful of people in
the conservative media who will break
through that kind of mainstream
gatekeeper and actually tell you what's
really going on it's good when that
happens to expose these things
that can't be the end of the story
the end of the story cannot be look at
how crazy the left is wow they're
hypocrites
they those guys man they're bad they say
that they're good but they're really bad
that can't be the end of the story the
end of the story has to be yeah it's bad
we've exposed the problem we see the
problem
after that diagnosis we need to take
action okay
the the end of the story has to be
we elect new school board members and
they immediately fly into action
fire the crazy teachers fire the
superintendent fire the chairman of the
school board kick all of them out and
start Banning these pornographic books
from schools
you have to do stuff
and the libs aren't going to like that
and the libs are going to try to try to
convince the conservatives that actually
it's not very conservative to actually
do anything this is what happened for
the past 20 or so years on the right is
that the libs convinced the the right to
adopt this kind of weird libertarian
kind of shallow ethos where the
conservatives convinced themselves that
doing anything in politics is somehow
immoral or unprincipled well it would be
you know if we do anything
then that would make us no different
from the left the left you see puts a
bunch of weird porn in schools but if we
take the weird porn out of schools we're
no different than the left no we're
totally different that's the opposite
actually you're saying if we wield
political power we're no different from
the left no I guess we would be
we would be similar to the left in that
we would be actually participating in
politics
but we would be the opposite of the left
because we would be doing the opposite
things they want to make our country
worse we want to make our country better
they want to Pedal falsehood we want to
Peddle the truth we want to reveal the
truth and inculcate the truth in the
minds especially of young children this
is why education has become such a flash
point
because for years the conservatives we
threw up our hands we were treated from
the Public Square we said well you know
I don't I you do you but I don't I'm not
a hero okay I'm just going to go off to
my own little island and that's not
going to work because that just gives
the political space all over to the left
so now conservatives have woken up
this occurred during the Trump years
this was really one of the consequences
of the new trumpian approach to politics
which is not really new at all
it's actually a reversion to the old
right it's a reversion to how
conservatives rightly understood
politics to be until about 20 25 years
ago
and and the moms started showing up to
the school boards
and then the moms started electing
people
and then the moms are the reason why
Glenn youngin became the Republican
governor of Virginia
and the moms are the reason why Rhonda
Santos has been so successful in Florida
and what is one one of Ron desantis's
greatest pieces of legislation he's
passed it's the stop woke Act
the stop woke act which says no we are
going to have standards we are going to
have Norms we're going to give parents
rights and education
we're not going to let these radicals
just poison the minds of children
and so now
the libs are relying not on the people
the people love to stop woke act the
people hate it when the radicals try to
poison our kids brains with weird race
stuff and transgenderism and all the
rest of it so now the left is relying on
the judges and the judge the judges are
trying to stop the parents from having a
say over their kids education right now
head on over to genucel.com Knowles what
if I told you that you could make those
Fine Lines forehead wrinkles dark spots
even under eye bags disappear sounds too
good to be true right well it's not when
you make genuine cell skin care a part
of your daily routine genucel has sold
over 1 million products to both men and
women and the reviews speak for
themselves Samantha writes quote I love
genucel skin care I've used it all over
my face under my eyes and it cleared up
the dry flakiness and even reduced my
forehead lines
someone even asked if I had had work
done geniusell uses a proprietary base
with clinical levels of Botanical
extracts which come together to yield
amazing results geniusell products are
natural cruelty free and made in the USA
take advantage of geniusell's early
Black Friday sale going on right now you
can get their most popular products
package for over 70 percent off you'll
get two months worth of their best
sellers plus their hyaluronic acid serum
free with your purchase take advantage
of this amazing deal now by going to
genucel.com Knowles and use code Knowles
for an extra 10 off that is genucel.com
Knowles genucel.com Knowles
this is what a chief U.S District Judge
Mark Walker just said as he issued a
preliminary injunction to stop the stop
woke Act
stopwoke by the way refers to stop
wrongs to our kids and employees
politicians love a good initialism they
do or a good acronym so
uh this is what the judge had to say
about it the judge says that lacking
explicit standards to circumscribe
enforcement of objectivity defendants
can weaponize this term to further
discredit the eight Concepts in the
marketplace of ideas which now permits
endorsement of only one side of the
debate accordingly because this
objectivity savings Clause commands the
entire statute the IFA this is another
way to refer to the stopwoke act as the
individual Freedom Act is impermissibly
vague on its face in violation of the
due process clause of the 14th Amendment
let me translate that gobbledygook into
English for you
the judge is saying that by uh by
kicking
radicalism and transgenderism and
critical race Theory and all this
nonsense out of our schools that we're
threatening the free Marketplace of
ideas
then we'll only have one side of the
debates now two problems with this one
would you describe classrooms today as a
free Marketplace of ideas where all
sides are heard and well represented
or would you describe it as an
ideological Echo chamber where only
leftism thrives
obviously it's the latter the idea that
there is a free Marketplace of ideas in
our classrooms today is completely
Preposterous I I don't think I need to
explain myself you've all seen the
videos of me and other people going to
classrooms all around the country you've
been to school yourself your kids have
been to school you understand what this
means but second of all
even if there were such a thing as a
free Marketplace of ideas in classrooms
there really shouldn't be certainly not
in elementary schools or middle schools
do you really believe a fourth grade
classroom is supposed to be a free
Marketplace of ideas where new
scientific discoveries are being made of
course not it's a place to learn your
ABCs and two plus two equals four and
boys are boys and girls or girls the
problem is that these days the kids in
the schools are learning the two plus
two equals five and the little Johnny
actually can be little Jane just don't
tell your parents head on down to the
guidance counselor and he's going to
give you some puberty blockers that's
what's happening
there of course there's no free
Marketplace of ideas
in Early Education at the very least
there is coercion to learn a certain set
of facts and if you get those facts
wrong on your test you're going to get a
bad grade and flunk out that's what it
really is
yeah even the justification for a free
Marketplace of ideas is that well that
will allow new discoveries to be made
and Advance the human race it's a
dubious Prospect in many in many cases
but let's say even that that were true
even if it were true that's not
happening in third grade okay it's just
complete nonsense from the federal judge
who is threatened
is feeling threatened that leftism is
not going to have its absolute
establishment in the elementary schools
and throughout education federal judge
in Florida stopping Ron desantis's stop
woke act by claiming it threatens the
free Marketplace of ideas that doesn't
exist but also saying this he says one
thing is crystal clear
both robust intellectual inquiries and
democracy require light to thrive our
professors are critical to a healthy
democracy and the state of Florida's
decision to choose which viewpoints are
worthy of Illumination and which must
remain in the shadows has implications
for us all if our Priests of democracy
are not allowed to shed light on
challenging ideas then democracy will
die in darkness there's a federal judge
writing this nonsense but the First
Amendment does not permit the State of
Florida to muzzle its University
professors impose its own Orthodoxy on
viewpoints of viewpoints and cast us all
into the dark
hold on
the First Amendment
does not permit the State of Florida to
impose its own Orthodoxy of viewpoints
on the
Priests of democracy which is how the
judge describes the professors you see
do you see the problem there
the judge is saying
that the the people of Florida the
people as represented by the state
have no right
to have their own moral views
they have no right to impose that
Orthodoxy into the classroom and by
impose it means set the standards for
the community that that is going to be
taught to the children
instead the priests of democracy have
that exclusive right to impose their
Orthodoxy so he's saying the people
don't have the right to Orthodoxy to
their beliefs it's it's the leftists
they're the only ones with the right to
their Orthodoxy which is evil and wrong
I just any time someone tells you
leftism is not a religion please quote
them judge Walker's opinion on the stop
woke act he is admitting it is a
religion the professors or the priests
of that religion he then goes on to
quote a a slogan from a left-wing
newspaper The Washington Post
democracy will die in darkness I mean
this is really sad stuff
really sad stuff that a federal judge
has the intellect and education that
stops at the level of popular newspaper
slogans really pathetic how far our
country has fallen but an important
reminder
that this is a religious battle and I
know there's a lot of conservatives who
say I'm not all that religious I'm sort
of agnostic oh come on enough with the
religion talk
I didn't I didn't start the religion
talk okay
the religion talk is all around politics
because all human conflict is
theological it's the left that is
imposing the religion talk
the religion of leftism
the priests of which are the professors
in the universities and the teachers and
all the rest of the apparatchics in this
hierarchy of the Church of leftism
and the only way to fight that bad
religion is with good religion nature
abhor is a vacuum man is fundamentally a
religious being okay we have ultimate
questions that we have to answer that
inevitably we are going to Grapple with
what is death what is judgment is there
a heaven is there a hell what am I for
what is the good life who made me what
is what is life what is those are
questions that will not be answered by
history
or natural science or I don't know
chemistry they can't be answered by
those things those are questions that
ultimately have to be answered by
religion and they will either be
answered by false religion like the
religion of Judge Walker here or by True
Religion by Christianity by the religion
that animates and built our entire
civilization and you've got to pick a
side if you stand in the middle of the
road you will be run over by a truck
you're you're either with God or against
God Is What It ultimately comes down to
okay and I think what the greatest trick
the devil ever played is pretending that
he doesn't exist and for a long time
the leftists have pretended that they're
just secular you know they're just
secular they're they don't have this
religion stuff that's all Hui from the
Dark Ages or whatever no they're
admitting it they're admitting that they
have a religion so you're either going
to be part of their religion or you're
going to be part of True Religion I
advise you to Choose Wisely you know the
rest of the show starts now
we have got a really important stuff
today this is fake headline Friday I
have been on an absolute tear Ben Davies
is so upset because I keep guessing the
fake headline I need your help to do it
if you're not a member click the link in
the description and join us
foreign
[Music]
[Music]